hello wordsmiths the word we're
featuring in this video is policy which
means an official rule or set of rules
it's a noun
it comes from the Greek word polis which
means City
as a root it has to do with cities and
government
I live in Washington DC so when I think
of this route I think of the Capitol
building itself a government building in
the middle of the city where rules or
policies are created
can you think of words that sound
similar to policy that might have that
same root polis bear in mind that
sometimes we drop the s in Palace when
making new words I'll give you 10
seconds to list some out
cue the music wall
[Music]
here are three related words I thought
of
police the people who enforce the law
politics or how people make decisions
together in a society and Metropolis
huge City
so you can see how all of those words
are related to governments or cities
let's use policy in a sentence so you
can get a sense of it
it's a state policy in Florida that if
you encounter a manatee in the wild
you have to give her ten dollars
the connotation the feeling of policy is
that it's an official rule so something
that a business or a government might
come up with a restaurant might have a
strict policy against bringing in some
other restaurants food our policy
no outside food or drink oh no this
Manatee went into a restaurant with food
from another establishment
the d stands for dugong which is another
kind of sea cow
that's all the time we've got for this
one tip your server support your local
Manatee and you can learn anything
David out